to a big election overseas where voters
in israel are casting ballots this
morning in the country's
fourth election in two years the
election is a referendum on prime
minister benjamin netanyahu who is
facing corruption charges
but also rolled out a successful covet
vaccination program one of the most
successful in the world
another change this time around a
familiar ally
is not playing a role in this campaign
that would be former president trump
elizabeth palmer reports now from tel
aviv
israelis are emerging into a
post-pandemic world and the economy is
fully open in the carmel market in tel
aviv business is good
at david shwarma stand we ask who gets
the credit
[Music]
the vaccine he says and the prime
minister
only baby bibi is the local nickname for
benjamin netanyahu
whose face during the campaign appeared
right next to the official vaccination
slogan back to life
but his opponent's banners remind
everyone that netanyahu remains
on trial for serious fraud he denies
those charges
and back in january decided vaccinating
everybody here was the key to
re-election
he got the ball rolling fast and it's
worked
yesterday only one person died of covet
netanyahu gambled that defeating the
virus would bring
victory at the polls voters are coming
this morning in a steady stream
to deliver the verdict but netanyahu is
facing
huge opposition every saturday night
massive demonstrations have filled the
streets around his home in jerusalem
his critics are furious about his
alleged corruption
and policies they say have embittered
israeli society
so you don't think netanyahu deserves
credit for the vaccine
oh no oh no i think you deserve jail
as you can see from the lines behind me
balloting is well underway now
the latest polls give benjamin netanyahu
about
a 50 50 chance of winning the next
election
tony all right we shall see elizabeth
palmer for us in israel liz thank you
very much